[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Jessica is supposed to say welcome back
uh coming up today you guys we're
talking about Avatar keeps it in the
family hey step bro
I'm stuck in this washer the wishes are
back you guys Hocus Pocus 2 drop today
dropped at midnight if you were on my
Twitter
um and I'm very excited and we run down
the rumor mill what is a rumor mill
we'll find out that's a real way to keep
the rumors that's where they harvest
Millers
rumors I've been drinking
milk I have it I have it for legal
purposes I have it oh my God and thank
you once oh settle down we're here with
Tom Mickelson hey how's it going Michael
that's okay
but different exactly like the golfer
but not like the golfer but like
Michaelson yeah I'm on the mic bro Tom
on the mic exactly and Jessica Clemens
who cares and then Thomas no it's
pronounced
it's true oh damn well
your mustache got so creamy and we got
John Costa my name is the stage name
what's your real name Edward Cullen whoa
whoa why didn't you go with that happy
Halloween oh my God Halloween is
officially begun on the break room oh my
gosh you guys we're so excited to bring
you this show today it's Friday we're
partying we just got paid yeah we're
gonna pay rent
I'm sorry real quick uh camera four if
you can hey guys I know that it's
October please don't touch my AG ones uh
and I understand that right now those of
you living in your dumpsters and
recycling bins are like well when is it
going to be our turn to carve the
pumpkins the rotting pumpkins will start
entering your garbage cans on October
20th okay and then you can recarve them
November repurpose them October 20th is
what I meant uh uh because you know
people carved from too early and they
rotten Anthony so you'll get the first
wave of riding pumpkins in about three
weeks so do not panic also I'm starting
uh a charity no you're not uh what's it
called it's called Uh thirsty Tommy's
pumpkin sucking patch I've heard we're
donating pumpkins to uh underserved uh
dumpsters and trash people all over the
SoCal area so if you're living in a
dumpster uh call in and we'll come give
you a pumpkin and I'll suck on it for a
bit oh no
I'm not doing anything but you know what
I am donating to these headlines hey
[Applause]
so Brandon I care about you Brandon and
the chip hey Brando when is your name
gonna change from off-screen producer
Brandon because because he ain't here
Brandon we're so happy you're with us
from our gourds to our oh Lord
that's a good one
a thousands
that was really good when I was trying
to guess it in an interview with variety
Sigourney Weaver oh God bless her says
Avatar 2 is based on James Cameron's own
family a poor man Jesus
oh wait a minute I guess I don't I'm
just assuming that he was on like a boat
he's been married like nine times has he
married two uh Linda Hamilton he was
leading to Catherine Bigelow
famously said that he's a bad husband
did she I think so that might be a
spoiler for Avatar too maybe but a hell
of a friend in a great mechanic
it's according to even said the story is
about uh is about family about our
families trying to stay together the
lengths to which we all go to protect
each other and protect the place where
we live you know what I hate about this
movie that I'm I mean I'm excited for
this movie but but Tommy you've seen
footage of this apparently Sigourney
Weaver is in the movie and she's also
playing her own daughter yes a 14 year
old girl I don't know about that I don't
I feel good about it it's yeah it's yet
unexplained you can do some inferring
from the footage and I don't want to
give spoilers but it does appear as
though like they've uploaded her
conscience into a child but the child is
not completely so the child is a human
child no the child is it Navi but it's
like in the same kind of the same way
that Jake Sully is uh is it not is this
because she passed away in the first
yeah and then remember they put her in
the tree yeah my dog is now eating the
stupid pellets that you guys have been
shooting yeah
they're actually good for dogs
guys Hocus Pocus 2 is out now it's
spooky season baby I just shot my
breakdown that'll be on our Channel next
week you guys gotta check it out hooks
books too is very fun for me and I cried
in it um I'm also having an emotional
week so it could be that but I think it
was just because the movie's really good
I like drinking AG ones because it makes
me feel like I just had an entanglement
with She-Hulk you know I'm just so wow
even sponsoring us today yeah there they
are oh man just hang in there oh my God
we wanted to introduce a new little
segment on the show called rumor man
is there a graphic for that or what I'll
never tell you no graphics
choke on one
I'll never know the rumor mill I know
okay little gel balls these are these
are stories we can't Source or confirm
you guys that's why hence the name Rumor
Mill but from some of the things we're
hearing we believe them to be true okay
okay so our first our first of the rumor
mill yeah these are exciting our first
rumor is that we're getting a new
trailer for Black Panther rakana Forever
on Monday and tickets will also go on
sale that same day uh we did just get
some new images from the film too that
we want to show you let's look at it I
don't know I might have done a miss
communicado and dashboard might not have
put those on there oh no give us the
Thirsty thespians graphic again quick
quick quick in the back quick absolutely
thank you
but we can uh we can describe them
because we've seen them uh and you can
find them online Empire magazine are the
folks who put them out I think whatever
they get all the good images they get
those good images
uh it was a there's a shot of uh Lupita
nyong'o's character in her sort of
funeral attire oh the white yeah the
white yeah we've got uh ramonda and Riri
Williams in a couple of shots uh there's
a really great shot of mbaku wearing his
new costume he's got like this cool ape
like chest piece that looks really sick
so go check those out we think we're
getting a trailer on Monday because we
think we're getting ticket sales on
Monday so that tracks in terms of like
how far in advance they'd come out it's
gonna be the hardest thing I hear a lot
of a lot of people in the chat clamoring
for the quiz Master the quiz master has
been detained by the FBI is being held
the Guantanamo Bay they were waiting for
her outside of the outside of the room
when she wrapped it was one of those you
guys were questioning what year they
were born or where they were alive
oh no well quizmaster claimed to be 280
years old I think uh fleshiana is also
weirdly missing but garage door Ann is
here so that's good what
by the way our next rumor is that uh bo
de Mayo Bo demaio we're saying bodes a
man because it's more fun is that
Cinco's brother
it took me a second
I'm so upset it took me too long time no
it's doing gracias
Beau is doing a page one Rewritten
rewrite on blade page one is an industry
term for throwing the whole script away
just tossing it and starting from
scratch looking like we won't get that
one by November 2023 after unless he
pulls uh Zach Braff and writes Garden
State in 48 hours did he really how much
of the game did he use Zach Braff yeah I
don't know a horse's portion well he was
able to get a killer soundtrack
uh you've never done horse rails before
no that's when you line up just
a baseball field line yeah you know what
I'm saying and it's like we're just
kidding guys for legal purposes once
again everyone here is Stone sober and
has never done drugs or drank alcohol oh
thank you but I I heard of that because
they're the what the rumor is is that uh
the script is only like 90 Pages which
is not a lot only has like two very
flimsy actions I heard mostly drawings
too yeah like mostly crayon drawings
it's just him gonna be standing there
like flipping Pages Like Love Actually
but it's all blade content yeah it's
cool it's a lot of proclamations of
blade is going to his neighbor and it's
like I know I can't have you but to me
you're perfect and if I could I would
suck you drink they're like sir this is
an Arby's
all right they have the meats okay
okay
this is the problematic side of the
table all right nothing will get done
now problem town on here
's where we get crazy oh my God so
Marvel just released a new featurette
for their upcoming werewolf by night TV
special and we have a clip so let's show
we're introducing a world that will
ultimately become quite important to the
future of the MCU it's time to like put
something different out into the world
it's going to be so cool yeah
thank you
so much important to the Future
that's incredible hey Raul Lillian
please be safe
and by the way call me later all right
after the show people are putting bunny
horses in the chat for a horse rails
horse rails it's a horse and a train
okay
it's gonna get the wrong impression
people are gonna think we're railing
horses we're doing horse rails so that
would be the rail before the horse
speaking of which Santa Anita race track
opens around
about this are you ready you better
believe it someone in the chat leave me
a three number combo I'll bet it on the
first race it's not going it's not gonna
be in a box of leave in a box guaranteed
whoa I'm just saying you're gonna go
hard I'm just saying
not a day in our lives are we excited
for work type of work no I'm not excited
I hate Halloween I hate spooky things I
don't like werewolves is this is this is
this one is werewolf by night when we
should drop our first break room
sleepover watch party should we watch
that should we stream it live watch it
live people can watch with us when it
drops it's a Friday night right tweet at
us if that's something if you guys are
interested call in send us a piece of
written mail uh or if you put it in the
chat because we can also give me your
phone number we could also like tie up
and make a little tent in here and just
be in our foodie pajamas
werewolf by night yeah and just kiss
each other I just find it interesting
that that feige says it's it's really
this this movie is important to the the
future of the MCC you because you know a
lot of the speculation we were doing
about blade was that they loved so much
about what they got from werewolf by
night and they weren't seeing that in
the blade stuff and maybe now they're
sort of redoing the blade stuff so that
we can go from the tone of of projects
like werewolf by night into you know
properties like blade and maybe midnight
suns in the future and it's also it was
also reported early on that you know
Michael giankina was the one who pitched
this to Kevin feigen he's like really
you want to do werewolf by night so it
ended up being some kind of afterthought
to now being something super important
to you interested in it because of the
way that everyone's talking about it
even like the people inside Marvel it's
like it felt like At first they were
like yeah it's just gonna be our holiday
special we're just gonna make it
whatever and then it's the biggest thing
that's today right now and I'm like wait
you guys kind of it felt like they kind
of not like a throwaway but it felt like
like they were like I'm not gonna expect
too much and it's getting great reviews
all right someone in the chat is asking
uh if we have Redemption today uh we
don't redemptions will be back next week
took a little time off but if we raise
five thousand dollars Tommy and I will
kiss at the end
everybody if you raise five dollars
Tommy and I will kiss at the end of the
episode but you won't get to see it if
we if we raise 50 me and John will kiss
uh all the time whoa and if we raise 2.5
million dollars the four Russell spring
break triple quadruple kiss the way I
remember they used to do that on MTV
a lot of the Old Spring Break triple
quadrome none of you guys were born none
of you guys oh three girls from your
city whoa whoa thank God I've been
waiting for it that's the girls in my
city have been paid that's that's my
that's my favorite uh you're being paid
that's my favorite Rolling Stones album
free gift from your city
the girls are free in the city tonight
they're going down to the disco dance
and the free guest in yesterday
okay that was pretty good thank you
thank you thank you we're gonna end the
show there on the face he wants more
freaking gems hey you want some more
give you some later okay good job guys
you can't feed the dog beads have we
done anything
podcast
I've been trying to say it on the phase
zero podcast werewolf By Night director
Michael
giacchino giacino giacino maybe I'm
Italian okay I think it's not that's
probably right Pinocchio revealed that
most of the effects in the special we're
practical including the transformation
of Jack Russell into the werewolf all
practical which I didn't once their
photos released to them so this is
specifically talking about there there's
like I think they're gonna do I think
they're gonna do one of those classic
sort of they've been doing this a lot in
She-Hulk where they like will cut away
when she's transforming into She-Hulk
maybe to save money or something yeah
but I think what they're gonna do is we
saw the shot of uh Chris and Ritter not
Kristen Ritter
um in the cage and you saw him transform
into the werewolf in like Shadow behind
her that was all practical and I think
they then get a cut to the actor in
makeup or it might be like thriller or
like Michael J fox where just like hair
started coming over his hands he said
Thriller and then he said Michael J fox
yeah well was the American you're
talking about Teen Wolf sorry I'm
talking about American werewolves it was
all practical too though
today is Friday which means it's time
for another fresh base Friday brought to
you by our good friends at geology oh my
goodness Chris live right that's pretty
good I hate to be John right now what
happened to me
this is a segment where we celebrate a
new face uh to the MCU and this week
we're introducing you to again not
Christian Ritter but Laura Connolly who
will be debuting as Elsa Bloodstone in
the upcoming Marvel special presentation
werewolf finite and I say that because
every time I've seen a trailer someone
in the comments have been like was that
Jessica Jones the answer is no uh
although that would be fun uh but but uh
Laura Connolly is a North Irish actor
and you might know her work from uh the
Nevers or Outlander but soon hunting
down monsters in black and white so
whether you're tracking mythological
beasts or just walking around town you
want to rock a face with fresh well
hydrated skin at least I do and so does
my wife and that's where our friends at
geology come in they offer a whole range
of products to help your skin look its
best they'll even help you find products
best suited for your specific needs I
got an oily forehead and a dry under my
nose uh we're not going to talk about
why I was going to say what's drying it
out but geology has specific products
that are tailored exactly for my needs
because I took a quiz and you could take
that same quiz at geology.com new
rockstars and they'll suggest this
perfect lineup of skincare items for you
so head to geology.com new rockstars to
use our promo code rockstar70 to save
70. an insane discount 70. I'm a man who
likes to keep his skin creamy and dreamy
you guys know that I'm a green boy I've
always been a creamy you're a soft boy
I'm a soft Saucy boy with creamy skin
and hands that have never seen a tough
day in their life what aren't you also
um yeah that's I love doing the geology
ads for that I'm always like 70 off 70
70. we have no excuse and can you eat
the products when you're done using them
I couldn't tell you that okay you can
try they're right here all right if we
raise five thousand dollars Tommy's
gonna eat some geology
yeah yeah it says uh consuming will kill
you within minutes
also yes Chad I was sad every time John
brings up his wife oh my wife it's
Jessica
surprise She-Hulk we got two more two
more episodes to go I know incredible
and uh uh one of our favorite Reddit
users uh who maybe you know I don't know
if he's a good guy or not but he's been
helpful uh his name is uh
costaspat257. are you watching it's not
my ALT
um and that Lillian your chats have been
out of control today Lily please donut
skin I'm worried about it moist uh I'm
excited uh that user has been compiling
some really cool cuts of like the
remaining She-Hulk trailer footage uh
that haven't been shown yet and we
wanted to just kind of take a look at
some of that footage and play do a
little breaking down of what this
footage might mean and where this is
going to go up to this episode so let's
let's run that there's no audio so uh
we're just gonna we're just gonna talk
over it yeah Abomination okay she's like
fired
still frames of all this in a second but
we just want to run through all this
yeah fight scene of the gala this is the
Daredevil Gala in the yeah
foreign
[Music]
stuff as well or Daredevil stuff and and
some Daredevil stuff yeah he's The Man
Without Fear and then this cool shot uh
of her uh walking up the steps of what
looks like the DA's building you know
it's funny he missed something oh no
let's hear it he missed the part in the
trailer where it's uh it's uh Mark
Ruffalo and Her Standing On Top of the
roof
that's interesting I almost pulled that
image it does it does look very 70s it's
a throwback reference to some of the old
1970s Hulk TV show
um and and maybe that got cut out at
some point
I think
it win they're like we can just lock
this in
yeah we haven't touched on it and I
don't think we're gonna see yeah Bruce
Banner comes back then they'll have to
start asking some other questions one
little thing yeah just add to what
you're saying we talked about this in
inside marble there is only two episodes
left we do not have enough time to get
into LeapFrog why Titania broke into the
courtroom that if that's behind the
Beatles who's behind the needles by the
needles
first things first I wanna I wanna bring
up an image that Jessica talked about a
little bit in her breakdown that's out
now on the channel yeah uh go check it
out if you haven't done so already but
can we bring up that first image of a
meal
um yeah so there's a shot of a meal
plotsky transformed back into a bio
Nation but if you look sort of at the
location here
he's got these inspirational posters up
that we saw at his retreat center but to
me this this uh location feels more like
hunting lodge than it is are those
antlers
chandelier than it does you know like
like the logic we've already seen so so
at some point uh Emil is going to
violate his Patrol uh his parole and
turn back into the Abomination amidst
like a a gaggle of uh fans and followers
maybe like a book signing or something
like that yeah Theory so it is it's so
insane to think about this because I
don't want it but ever since Emil showed
up I think that's been the long gang
that's why he chose her as he was like I
just want to make amends he didn't
really want to make amends he was
actually working with the intelligencia
setting this all up and I really don't
want Emil to be bad right but I think
that's the great writing that the show
is giving us is like we don't want him
to be bad just like Josh we love them
that turn was always written and it was
always there we just didn't want to look
at it so I think Emil's just setting
this up for the long game and that is
another place that's on the compound
that she just hasn't seen totally I
think this is what I think
I think he's a meal is not going to be
bad but he is he is Desiring to be able
to turn into Abomination again I think
he now views himself in a heroic light
and I think he's going to Stage
something at that whatever that Lodge is
that requires him to turn into
Abomination much like much like Wong in
his fights were kind of like not staged
but were like bought and paid for by
Wong and I think it's like syndrome and
the incredible yeah I think it's going
to be a like I have to turn into him
because he's wearing the shirt the shirt
still fits right like obviously he's
seen the tailor right like we have to
assume he's been to uh right Lucas Jacob
he's just like always as like also I
like the fit on that shirt he kind of
looks like Dwayne The Rock Johnson he
looks like a chef it looks like a chef
chicken I thought you said that because
that ties into another theory I have is
I was thinking that he might end up
being in the Thunderbolts hopefully and
that'll be part of his characterization
that they need eat a heavy like the
Abomination but he's going to be this
nice guy that doesn't like to hurt
people anymore and and that's going to
be his character is the contradiction
that would be a usual post-credits
yeah they're coming and him joining with
them that was my pitch at the very
beginning of the show and it is so so
much change and I want to agree with
Tommy and his theory really badly but
I'm also just like I don't like that
that room is kind they play really hard
the heightening of like hey not all men
act like this but we're gonna make sure
you notice this is how men act on the
show yes it's a room full of men in that
cabin with the deer antlers like I just
don't even if he did something good and
they're high-fiving him I'm like this is
a room full of nothing so and what I
know from this show is every time
there's a group of men nothing but bad
things have happened so far that's very
true except that the year man oh God
right here oh God please don't break the
table again I have to fix the table if
you guys my rage is Unbound we also get
this shot of Jennifer in her bedroom
with some of her belongings in a
banker's box now we cross-referenced
this with earlier episodes just to make
sure this hadn't been in the show yet
um when she did get fired from the DA's
office it was not in that second episode
when she gets fired
um it's possible simple it's possible
that this was shot for that episode and
ultimately got cut but still made it
into some promos but it hasn't been in
the show yet and and so I would
speculate that there's a shot that
follows that of like some reporters at
her off at her at her building that we
also did not see
this is very possible as we get to some
of the other shots in this that um you
know perhaps blotsky violating his
parole me I keep saying Patrol parole
means that he she gets canned it could
be possible that some of the things that
we see in these next few shots are what
gets her fired
um and maybe I was thinking those could
also happen out of order like maybe yeah
she gets in trouble everybody's hiding
her house so she has to move and that's
maybe a place that she moves to to kind
of Escape yeah very possible very
possible similar to we what we saw in
Spider-Man no way home and that those
scenes led us to a certain character
that we know we're going to be getting
in this show as well so who knows
um but that takes us to our next shot we
have She-Hulk arriving at some kind of
Gala or Gala depending on
um how you pronounce that wow break the
news things go wrong there's all these
crazy red flashing lights we have some
government officials that show up with
um he's got those like handheld Canon
things we saw bigger versions of those
in the Incredible Hulk most recently we
saw them in Miss Marvel so so best guess
is that's probably the dodc the
department of damage control that sort
of comes to that Gala
um best guess there right is that
whoever is heading up the Intelligentsia
we suspect Todd
um has probably injected himself with
some of that good old Hulk juice yeah it
is now sort of coming in to uh
they only want me for my heart
so this is another instance where it's
possible that Jen gets fired from GLK H
because of whatever she's doing this
vigilante justice stuff that she's doing
at this Gala yeah all right well the
stuff that she's doing that's the gala
for the women's lawyer
right she's the female lawyer you're
right which it could also be that that's
the meet-up point for Daredevil and she
has her suit underneath because we see
that scene later that's like the same
kind of wrecking crew kind of lights and
them going against each other so I think
she's going underground kind of like in
Hawkeye when Kate Bishop was like I need
to go put on my suit and just like went
underground where everything was
happening it'll kind of mirror that
situation that's what I'm hoping because
I'm tired of her being set up right and
we see you know we see this is obviously
takes place at night obviously there can
be multiple night scenes that happen in
the last two episodes but like that
could definitely take us from the gala
to the LeapFrog stuff to the Daredevil
stuff yeah I don't know when leapfrog's
coming in that part is very confused so
we know right we know that LeapFrog and
Daredevil and Jennifer are all connected
to Luke Jacobs in the fashion designer
right so like we have to go back there
she has to get her suit again uh
Daredevil has to go back there mad
Murdock he has to get his suit we saw
the actor who plays LeapFrog in that
building already so like I wouldn't be
surprised if Luke Jacobson comes back
and uh you know I don't know we get to
see a scene with a bunch of people that
have been teased throughout this thing
but the next shops we get are of
Daredevil LeapFrog She-Hulk um in a few
different locations here
um my guess is that Daredevil is
probably in town to pick up a suit maybe
do some layering on his own since um it
does seem like Matt and Jen grab a drink
at legal ease if you look at the
background of uh this it's similar Decor
to to legalese uh the bar that's been
amazing show so far we've brighten some
of this stuff does does
it maybe Matt
lawyer of the Year Awards
that's why he's in La yes
every year he's a great lawyer
he got he got Peter Parker off and he
couldn't that's right he couldn't get
happy Hogan off though but who can only
Marissa till May right yeah exactly oh
my God
she's dead and that robot that Tony gave
to happy as again
um uh so so what this tells us right is
that at some point Jennifer and Matt
will know that each other are lawyers
right obviously they're gonna meet each
other uh not in their costumes or in
their transformed States but I think
this is a good tip off that like they
might do some lawyering together or
against each other or they're not gonna
know actually either that is still
Jennifer obviously because he can
absolutely heartbeat he can smell her
like with all the other senses but he's
probably heard the news that there's a
lawyer in Los Angeles
yeah
we're talking about
um
so uh I also wouldn't be surprised if uh
Jennifer somehow gets fired from glkh
and joins uh uh Matt and uh Matt at his
Law Firm Nelson Murdock
um
Barbara give her a partner yeah yeah
Barbara Walters no she's got to earn it
it's like Mad Men you know she's gotta
smoke a lot of cigarettes and sleep with
a lot of hookers you can't give the
women the name on the on the building
too early wait what you guys stop stop
what are you talking about
[Laughter]
but has been online for a while now
um Titania actress Jamila Jamil uh
tweeted something out before the show
started I think that was like her and
Mark Ruffalo in costume together
um and she was just saying like how much
of a treat it was to work with Mark so
uh obviously if you look at the
background again there's a police car
there's a police car in the background
it could be the Gallup but it also could
be blonsky's Retreat Center we've got
that sort of is he having like an open
house cottage looking building there so
hope is definitely coming back in this
show at some point
um I don't think they would shoot all
this stuff and then not end up using it
the only thing I'll say is that
sometimes they shoot uh things out of
sequence and so the afternoon they may
be shooting another episode and the
morning so that's when they that's true
but this is a location shoe which makes
me think they're probably if they were
on a stage together totally but but
since they're on location it makes me
think they're probably going to share a
scene together yeah so uh now that we've
gone through all of that I have I have
questions for you guys oh right I
thought we were done
um that's just deleted baby
um the biggest question I have for all
of you guys is like okay we know we're
getting hope back do you think we're
gonna get any resolution to the Hulk on
sakar story or do you think that he's
just gonna kind of come back for for a
cameo or a save the day moment or or
whatever or saying goodbye and we're
gonna save that sakar stuff for another
project uh I think we're gonna get a
tease for furthering the story I don't
think we'll get resolution I think I
think maybe Hulk will come back and be
like
I I have learned some crazy [ __ ] we're
like like I'm only back for a minute
it's my son's birthday
you're what I'm imagining it's going to
be like moscanada it's like great
question for another time let's have the
rest of the show now yeah move on with
it
that's it what was the whole thing I
thought my dress on but it was it yeah
computer isolate image
enhance oh no I it go to the next one
and then maybe I'll come back the next
question yeah because I feel like uh
there's two episodes too much stuff and
maybe let me hear the other questions
first then I can deduce what I think
about the first one okay here's a little
more slew thing that we did yeah the
first four episodes were all directed by
cat coiro
um those were the episodes that all had
post-credit scenes the next three
episodes have been directed by a new uh
Valia
and those episodes did not have post
credit scenes so those are the seven
episodes we've had so far the following
two episodes the last two episodes are
going back to cat coiro right so that
leads us to kind of think like oh it's
possible that we'll have more
post-credit scenes for last time I would
like that and again with only two F's
left there's not enough time they gotta
give us some they gotta give us some end
credit plus plus you know you would you
would hope that the very last episode at
the very least would get end credits yes
yeah uh oh wait so my question is like
let's let's do a round table what's
what's your pitch for sort of a either a
cute end to the series or a bombshell
kind of like setting up future MCU stuff
um I got a slack message future MCU
stuff
um firstly I want to shout out Matthew
Gilbert who said he'll exit the
spaceship smoking a cigar hey
and then um we were gonna have to raise
a certain amount of money to do that I'm
not holding your breasts
I realized it was funny when we were
talking about it
here I'm going to set up the greatest
post-credits scene
of any Disney plus series ever it would
break the internet and uh so the post
credit scene is Jen Walters is things
things have returned to normal for
She-Hulk and she's like packing up or
something and she looks out at the
fourth breaks the fourth wall and goes
so yeah I guess uh I'm back to being an
everyday uh lawyer for the super powered
individuals uh and I love myself and
then someone from the fourth wall
answers back because who else is
breaking the fourth wall it's Deadpool
we just pan into a living room where
Deadpool and Wolverine are eating
popcorn and they have been watching
She-Hulk the series the whole time and
then Wolverine turns to Deadpool and
it's like why are you talking to her
because he doesn't know about the fourth
wall bridge wow that's what it is that's
the break I did have uh during our
She-Hulk predictions the one of the
things that I had predicted for the full
season was that at some point Jennifer
would be watching Disney plus
um but I like that I feel like I would
award myself partial points yeah I would
give you parts
I think the leader's gonna show up at
the very very last episode post credit
yeah okay I agree with that I think you
know they we know the leader is going to
be in New World Order we think we might
get Hulk in that in that movie as well I
I think the leader is a great bet Tim
Blake Nelson I think I know by the way I
don't think my post-credit scene is
going to happen I just wanted to I want
it to happen too it's like everyone
wants that to happen give me everyone I
want mine to happen first balls
somebody's super kid both by the way uh
the person that keeps asking us to wish
their Nan happy birthday happy birthday
no hey man
happy birthday baby
blows your candles out tonight oh my God
we stopped drinking like five episodes
but we're just getting overtly sexual to
him I don't know I'm just saying
someone's gonna blow she's a man she may
not have the wind power right her teeth
might fly someone else said talk about
Community movie yeah we all have an
opinion on the community movies if you
don't have the event Nicole Brown and
Donald Glover they shouldn't make it I
say do a whole movie that's just Chevy
Chase
get everyone else out of there someone
in the chat said Jessica be careful
around John if you're married to him and
now I know why because you are
supportive Chevy Chase oh yeah that
means it sounds like that new uh it did
nothing man movie
I'm I'm never around but always trying
to murder yes yeah yeah and always
watching um
I think we might see uh something in
sakar I think we might get a cheese of
sakar to set up a World War Hulk project
or something demoline
um and that as well I think setting up
something Hulk would be awesome or
they're gonna set up where she-hulk's
gonna be in the future kind of like a
shangshi to kind of set up that you know
the rings that are going to be playing a
role moving forward they might be doing
something like that with Jennifer
Walters being like here's where you're
going to be fitting moving forward maybe
she might have a cameo in secret
Invasion something else is coming up
soon totally uh maybe she might be
needing to represent somebody else yeah
I think or orates for Daredevil exactly
which is regardable yeah yeah yeah um
Jessica I'm coming back to this question
because you asked so nicely
will we see a resolution to the Hulk
sakar story are they going to save that
for a future project what do you think
what do you think future project okay
kick that can down the road we have a
lot to do in the next two episodes we've
got to introduce a new villain in in
Todd or whoever the intelligence he is
also if Todd is still the Hulk Todd we
it's like you got we gotta see that talk
by the end of the episode
hey
you wanted to switch Jess you want us
all right why do you guys think of you
super Chatters huh we got some great
super yeah I like to thank
I want to thank film juice
um speech I I'd like yes I would thank
them like an award sheet please I want
to thank Tanya Taylor Sorry Jessica
you're good I realized ours was that
wish my non a happy birthday it is a
lovely it is a lonely bread I don't know
what that means
Korean stuff it's pretty good film juice
get out of the chat I love your film
juice can't get enough of you you're uh
you're a Twisted Twisted Soul Mike
dollar sent in way more than a dollar
hey my more like my Mikey Dallas Tanya
Tyler did say just Titania this is her
explanation for how Titania busts into
the courtroom titanium's fleeing traffic
court it took the scenic route through
Justice I need to I need to uh I say
this a lot me and boss do without giving
the explanation I need to start
correcting myself I don't believe that I
don't believe that and I don't believe
she had low blood sugar I think she I
think it's something else and if the
writing is just that then that I'm gonna
be a little irritated but I don't it
feels a little too not enough picture
three though it's really good
are you off of that theory now the glkh
stuff oh yeah yeah that she was hired by
uh Holden Holloway so that she could
like uh just ruin the court yeah
desperate she's not a public figure yeah
that was my theory
hey John yeah do you know how much it
costs to put a chimney on uh put a
chimney in these days actually don't no
it doesn't cost anything they're on the
house we want to thank our sponsor today
athletic greens I'm a big fan of their
product ag-1 as you can see
oustic get all your daily nutrition in
one easy and tasty drink
yeah someone's got to scroll up
because I can't do the copy well he he
walked away I'm sorry that guy you were
so embarrassed by me owning him with
that joke with one delicious scoop of
ag1 you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Food Source
superfoods probiotics adaptogens to help
you start your day right this special
blend of ingredient supports your gut
health your nervous system your immune
system your energy recovery focus and
aging
John why do you want to get a chimney
put into your house right now uh because
all the suits just because they're going
through the roof with ng1 you're getting
an all-in-one nutritional insurance it's
much cheaper than sourcing all the
healthy ingredients yourself ag-1 is a
small micro habit with big benefits it's
one thing you can do every single day to
take great care of yourself and for
every purchase they donate to
organizations helping kids get
nutritious Foods we have food to kids in
need including no kid hungry here in the
U.S hey John did you hear about all the
Swedish battleships I have it yeah
they're putting barcodes on the front of
them so when they come to Port they can
Scandinavian arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition it's just one
scoop in a cup of water every day that's
it to make it easy athletic dreams is
going to give you a free one-year supply
of immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs
five free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com break room again that
is athleticgreens.com break room to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional Insurance
baby why did the werewolf leave summer
camp early because he missed his mummy
I didn't guess I was gonna try to guess
that one it's very funny ask any
five-year-old that joke
I'm wearing a lot of rooms I'm working a
lot of kindergarten classes now those
are my only gigs
activate tip what's that do they tip
no oh no no they just eat paste
JD said what's the difference between
roast beef and pea soup anyone can roast
beef oh my God anyone can pee soup if
you drink if you haven't or if you don't
drink enough if you're pretty dehydrated
that soup gets pretty viscous anyway
it's time for mandatory fun what'd you
say I was gonna say I saw it in the chat
someone I think was six eight zeros uh
Super Chat said uh Ali time that's hello
in Palau and the island that are from uh
allowing in the chat no way there's
plowing on the show the only two of us
in the world are here right now
oh and my mom sorry okay what a moment
your mom is dead I'm so sorry to tell
you oh no oh man
it's like when professional athletes
like don't want to hear about a family
member passing before a big game I'm
like no you should you should be with
your family don't go play a game of
football Vanessa Hudgens did that before
she did uh Greece she switched on her
hard house really she murdered
[Music]
oh my God I can't with you guys
nothing just go oh my God it's time for
mandatory fun
silence
that's how funny is the global
phenomenon where I gather my three best
friends in the whole world but they're
not here today so we'll do it no no my
three best friends that are here okay
Tom you speak for yourself
I only have a red flag so this oh you're
playing thank you one that's okay you're
gonna leave well we can share I'll hold
up my athletic greens if that's a green
flag for me uh all right we are it's
mandatory fun hit the graphic Again
YouTube early thank you no I'm sorry I
didn't realize you're playing I would
have found you agree uh we are playing a
game called red flag green flag I'm
gonna take us through a few superhero
scenarios okay and we will debate
whether we're gonna give them a red flag
or a green flag time to go through the
scenarios now okay first scenario he
takes you out to dinner okay he pays for
everything and then he clones your phone
while you are asleep wait wait read the
beginning
he pays for everything and then he
clones your phone while he's pulling the
Josh but it's not Josh this is just this
is
uh uh one two three
because he didn't take a picture of me
while I was sleeping that was a creepy
part yeah probably called my phone
I've seen your phone so many Nudes on my
phone oh they're all of me some of them
are drawings his wallpaper on his phone
yeah I don't think it's bad but also
it's like I would take no no no it is
bad it is bad it is bad it's bad I bet
for me because I'm gonna make him pay
for the most expensive dinners and most
expensive
it's kind of worth it to let him clone
your phone just for the maps I'm not
doing anything I'm not doing anything on
my phone as the guy who always pays for
the dinners if you know she wants to pay
him and give me a full night up
the guy who's never paid for a dinner
let me tell you I work on an apps for
apps plan you buy me apps you can take
the apps off my phone next
scenario it's true she has an erratic
work schedule she frequently stays out
all night but she's very loyal
oh okay one wait say one more time she
has an erratic work schedule a dog she
frequently stays out all night
but she's very loyal oh my God that is a
dog one two three
whoa red flags interesting I got no
problem with that
Independence yeah then there's no
nothing to be worried about I'm talking
about the squirrel from DC Super Pets
you guys are all bestiality
scenario that squirrel had a beautiful
smile he's a combination of AI and
synthetic biology but he has a calm
demeanor however he's also tough to
reason with one two three
and vision anytime yeah I mean white
vision and he could do anything why is
he got to be the Whitefish the ship of
Theseus yeah I get really mad sometimes
and I need someone to be like Jessica
let's talk it down I will say the the
vision that we've seen in the MCU has no
passion whatsoever which is except for
when he's except for the very beginning
of infinity War where he's like he's
like you're not allowed to leave the
compound I made you definitely yeah
let's talk about what they're in front
of the TVs right before he gets stabbed
yeah he's having romantic moments he's
like stay okay
yeah it's good it's good
this is supposed to turn me on it's
turned me off all right all right next
scenario my weirdos
my widows Charlie get me my widows uh we
were saying Danny DeVito should have
played Drake off uh the other day
off there this opportunity all right
next question next question he has a
crew of minions
all right who wrote These one two three
if you wouldn't [ __ ] Groot you're not a
human what that nose do am I right yeah
damn what are you doing Jessica what a
flag if he doesn't have a base
enslave these people if he doesn't have
a basement we don't have minions I don't
want if you watch the prequels they work
for him voluntarily they're not inside I
don't want them all the way up in my
business all the time they love it
you ever wanted to get a massage for
like a million hands at once yeah
I did that million hand March they call
it oh yeah it's the whole month of March
what yeah it's all march with all these
hands yeah and they March all over your
body all right next question uh they
have a house but it's very difficult to
access as a million a civilian
Oh I thought that was one of the things
good thing I'm in the armed forces okay
yeah how do we go to the house
Tony Stark
they don't have to be someone I thought
they all were these are these are these
are General relationships anyway these
are these are situations that came up on
Earth trying to get our advice
he's got a hate he's got a you gotta
clap through his cave that we can I
thought I'll show you a wet cave all
right next
I hate this they can shape-shift in
whatever you want them to be a baby one
two three can't be a red flag boom yeah
but they're real ugly in real life it's
the guy from it's the guy from uh the
boys
no but like what this is different is is
doppelganger like on compound V or
something no oh no he's just this uh how
can you be ugly in real life if you're a
shape-shifter if you're in real life
you're just whoever you well no offense
to the actor who plays Doppler I think
they probably purposely make him look as
bad as possible exactly kind of looks
like Carl from Aqua Teen Hunger Force if
you watch that show ever I love Carl he
he doesn't talk like him he's just like
a balding overweight man I you know yeah
no no we got the body over here but um
no the things
the green flag is because you know then
it could turn into like you know me and
just like homelander does for himself
you know what the [ __ ] Tom you gotta
watch
from a Transformer person that you're
dating is for them to turn into you oh
yeah Insanity hey if you don't love
yourself how can other people's love you
yeah you love yourself in private not
with someone else and that's the thing
and honestly someone else if you like
the way you look that much then baby you
should go and love yourself all right
that's it next one they have at least
three personalities they are extremely
attractive okay one two three I've
already dated that's a huge red flag it
looks on everything folks here's a red
flag trust me I've dated too baby
you gotta explain okay well first off
I'm assuming this is Moon night
um
and also I feel like I
can help
unwrapy Rappers
that's actually always available it's
actually the many different iterations
of C3PO after having its memory wise
no I'm just kidding it's midnight
finally our final question
[Applause]
are you gonna eat it oh damn
he can shrink down to a tiny size or
grow to a huge size one two three
termite
have a little bit more control you know
what I mean yeah can a pin particle give
you like a really specific size well if
you know we saw when the belt was broken
and Ant-Man and the WASP you know he did
go to some medium to some semi medium so
I'm sure you could set the dial
semi chat you are coming for me Chad
said what if Moon Knight didn't look
like Oscar Isaac Jessica that's not the
question Lillian the problem is he does
so yeah oh yeah horses and trains in the
chat please bring us home
I love red flag green flag she's great
you love it
for sending us a Super Chat that says I
love you three thousand Dirty by Nature
you're done with OPP other people's
postures
juice uh
Super Chat saying on The Hollywood
Reporter article reporting the blade
director has stepped away they do say
the Beau de Mayo is rewriting the script
who wrote the Moon Knight script he's
also the head writer on both season one
and season two of X-Men 97.
a good friend of a friend
um maybe we'll have him on the show one
day
[Music]
if we can get bow and Cinco on the show
I'll go nuts let me get some drinks um
uh here for the cookie Senator Super
Chat that said that segment should be
called the break Rumor Mill which is a
great name maybe we'll do the the you
want me to Crown you break Rumor Mill is
fantastic oh that makes sense well you
should have called it the break room
okay well I didn't have a lot of time
today come up with energy titles you did
a great job Corey kandro sent you the
Super Chat that said wait to John just
Freaky Friday and switch Tom and I have
always been switched this was just a
correction yeah true uh Rachel and uh
the MJ 2997 said quiz Mastery needs a
graphic first we want to get quiz Master
back on the show but again unfortunately
she is
yeah wow look look at that the truth
revealed
um let's see uh we also had Mikey cheers
Ellen Cho amadeus's Mom I don't get it
oh oh I think so is that his aunt but
yeah not all shows are related there's
nachos we got Corey Kendra again putting
in a
pumpkin a pumpkin sucking lips emoji in
the in the Super Chat there we go and
saying uh trash bag I need more quiz
Master f-bombs now she's she's you guys
Master did get us find 250 000 yesterday
you guys want me to curse I can curse
um no I'm not good at cursing hey uh the
next time we're gonna be here it's gonna
be October it's gonna be spooky as hell
uh we're gonna try to do a lot of fun
stuff for Halloween uh that's our show
for this that's it day that's it that's
our show for these this week
[ __ ] awesome weekend and the first
couple days I see your joke but I just
uh can't keep up his armies up and
sleeve he's okay that's better than the
one we've all heard that one though
that's a good joke film juice how do you
get a tissue to dance
put a little boogie in it hey oh I knew
that one we're gonna be boogieing all
day long off camera uh and we'll see you
guys next week thank you so much for
watching goodbye
[Music]